حياكم الله قال يا رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي المكلفه بنيامين نتنياهو في
مقابله مع موقع العربيه الانجليزي ان
اسرائيل لديها القدره على منعيرام من
امتلاك قنبله نوويه متعهده بمنع طهران من
امتلاكها وانه سيفعل ذلك حتى دون علم
واشنطن واوضح ان الاجراءات التي تم
اتخاذها ضد ايران قامت بها اسرائيل من دون
الولايات المتحده ومن دون موافقتها لانها
ربما لن توافق واضاف الى اخبرنا واشنطن
بما كنا على وشك القيام به فسيردون نحن
نعرضها وفي هذه الحاله سيكون صراعا مباشره
قوله مبينا انه في حال تم اخبار واشنطن قد
يتسرب الخبر للاعلام كصحيفه واشنطن بوست
او نيويورك تايمز وبالتالي المعلومات الى
طهران وهذا سيكون لدى الايرانيين تحذير
مسبق واضاف في مقابله
في المقابله بان تحالف التقليدي
الاسرائيلي الامريكي ومعه دول اخرى يحتاج
لاعاده تاكيد ولا ينبغي ان تكون هناك
تقلبات دوريه او حتى تقلبات حاده بهذه
العلاقه موضحا ان التحالف هو مارسات
والاستقرار في المنطقه
ليس متاخرا وايضا قمنا بالعديد من الخطوات
على هذا الصعيد لا استطيع الافصاح عنها
باستثناء ما قلته في سيره الذاتيه
المنشوره مؤخرا عن المغاره التي نفذتها
عناصرنا للوصول الى الارشيف السريه ونقله
الى اسرائيل وحصلنا على الكثير من
المعلومات القيمه في هذا الارشيف والجميع
بمن فيهم خصوم السياسيون يقرون بانني
تسببت بتراجع القدرات النوويه الايرانيه
من سب الى 10 سنوات ولكن هل اوقفناها لا
ولكن هل يمكننا ايقافه عسكريا وبطرق اخرى
الجواب اعتقد نعم ونحن بالتاكيد لن نسمح
لهم بالمضيما الان اذا سالت كيف يمكنك
ايقاف مثل هذه المشكله فلن اخذ في
التفاصيل التقنيه او الفنيه لكنني ساقول
انهم ما لم يكن لديك خيار عسكري موثوق به
ضد الدول المارقه مثل ايران التي تحاول
تسليح نفس باسلحه نوويه فلن توقفها اعتقد
ان الاجابه لا اعتقد اعرف الاجابه على
سؤالك هي لدينا الوسائل ولدينا الاراده
واذا لزم الامر سنفعل كل ما هو ضروري لمنع
ايران من امتلاك ترسانه النوويه
ينضم الينا من واشنطن ديفيد بولو
كالمستشاره السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه وكبير الباحثين في معهد واشنطن
لسياسات الشرق الادنى ومن تل ابيب عبر
زوما الدكتور
روفينا باركو الباحث السياسي
مع من واشنطن ومن هناك اسال كيف تقرا
واشنطن هذه الرسائل التي وجهها رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي لهذا التحالف القائم
بين
تل ابيب
شكرا انا اعتقد بصراحه كامله انه هذا ليس
من جديد نحن
كنا نسمع هذا الكلام من زمان من تنياهو
ومن
الزعماء الاسرائيليين الاخرى الاخرين لان
هذا بصراحه الطبيعي في العلاقات الدوليه
هناك نوع من تفاهمات
متبادله قويه
وواضحه ولكن في نفس الوقت كل طرف من طرفين
يحافظ على حوريه حوريه الاختيار المعنى
انه
لو التجات اسرائيل الى على سبيل المثال
هذا هو عسكري ضد المفاعيل الايرانيه
النوويه انا اعتقد ان هناك احتمال جيد
لعدم
المبلغ
اسرائيل واشنطن هل هو عدم ثقه لا انا
اعتقد انه كما قالوا
هناك نوع من مخاوف اسرائيل بالنسبه
لتسريبات مقصوده او غير مقصوده الى
الصحافه
والحقيقه انه نحن كل النهار هذا المشهد في
اسرائيل وفي امريكا وفي اماكن اخرى في
العالم من زمان هذا كمان عادي في العلاقات
الدوليه ولذلك حكومه
ما هذا هذا الكلام وان قلته انه ليس اا
كلاما جديدا وتسمعنا ولكنه ينبع عن عدم
همم عدم ثقه بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده وان هناك بون شاسع بين
الرؤيتين انا لا اعتقد انه هذا الدليل على
عدم ثقه بالعكس انا اعتقد انه عرضته
واشنطن يعني نتنياهو قال انه بواشنطن
ستعارض توجها اي ضربه لايران
هذا من الممكن وهمم لذلك انا اؤكد اكرر
انه كل ده وكل حكومه تحافظ على حوريه
الاختيارات وعلى همم
المحافظات او همم
الدفاع عن النبات وهذا ليس دليل على هذا
الثقه هذا طبيعي وهمم وانا اعتقد انه هذا
الاتجاه الاخير همم
العمليات العاديه
والثقافه
ارجو ان همم تبقى معي همم
باركو الباحث السياسي دكتور يعني كيف ترد
وكيف ترى ما تفضل به ضيف مباشره
اه يعني مساء الخير لكم جميعا
طبعا للضيف الامريكي الكريم انا موافق
مطلق
على اقواله
واكد ثانيه انه الدولتين شقيقتين مثل
اميراتيه تحافظ على حريه العنبر والدفاع
عن النفس
وتدافع عن مصالح البعض بشكل متبادل ولكن
لا يعني ذلك
القرار باي من الدوله
اللي هي الدوله المستقله ذات امكانيه
اتخاذ قرار لا بتبيعه الامر يعني حريه
اتخاذ القرار الملائم بالوقت الملائم تقبل
الولايات المتحده ان تقوم باسرائيل بتوجيه
ضربه مباشره الى ايران هل تعتقد ذلك
انا
برايي الموضوع مش ال ال التهيئات
المتزايده ما بين اسرائيل وامريكا
ورايينه شاهدنا تهيئات وتحضيرات سلكوم
للعمل العسكري المشترك ما بين اسرائيل و
الدول العربيه
والدول الخليج بما يتعلقك بالخطوات
المستقبليه اتجاه تهديد ونعوم في الايراني
ولكن هناك وانا اؤكد لك ايضا انه حتى داخل
جيش الدقه اذا كان عمل عمليات خاصه لا
يشاركون كل ظلمات
الارقام
بالخطط المستقبليه بل يحافظون الاسرار فقط
للقوه التي
ما نتكلم عن
العسكر نحن نتحدث عن ابلاغ دوله اخرى قد
تقبل ترفض توجيه ايضا الى همم ايران
وبالتالي ليس هو ليس عسكر وليس جندي ابلغه
بالتفاصيل هذه الولايات المتحده كخط
يعني احسنت بسالك وتاكيد اقوى جاوبك ضيفك
الكريم الامريكي حيث انه قال انه هناك همم
انا بالموقف الاسرائيلي ما في الموقف
الامريكي
انا بقول لك ايه
متساويان بيكون معنى الكلمه
ان تقوم بهذه الضربه وبالتالي تحمل
نتائجها وتحمل تبعاتها حتى ان الولايات
المتحده قد تعارض توجيه هذه الضربه
هل يمكن ذلك
يمكن ان تقوم اسرائيل بالضربه ايران اذا
اراد ذلك هو وصلت الى النتيجه انه هذا هو
العمل المقصود والمنشود في الوقت المحدد
التي الذي تختاره
ولكن بالخطوات الراهنه هذه ماهيه العلاقات
مصالح البعض ومن خلال
جنود هناك طيارين هناك يعني
ما تستطيع واملى الجيش
جنود والتيارين مهم جدا ولذلك الحفاظ على
السريه مطلقه يعني اذهب الى واشنطن دعني
اذهب الى الى واشنطن يستمزج ايضا راي ضيفي
ديفيد بولو كالمستشار السابق في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه اليوم اذا اذا البعض
يتحدث وحتى يعني نتنياهو قال التاكيد همم
على التحالف الامريكي الاسرائيلي وحتى
الدول الاخرى اذا كانت الولايات المتحده
الى الان رغم يعني همم
انتهاء نصف الولايه للرئيس الامريكي
لكنها لم تنجح بارسال الملف النوويه همم
مع ايران حتى لم توجه ضربه البعض يقول
بانها ايضا لم تكون
موقفا واضحا تجاه الاحتجاجات في ايران من
قبل الولايات المتحده لماذا كيف يثق
المتحالفون معها
بالولايات المتحده بهذا الموقع
الجواب حسب راي الشخصي هكذا اولا بالنسبه
للموقف الامريكي الرسمي تجاه البرنامج
نووي العسكري الايراني
لا شك انه
تعارض بشده وكسبت ايران على قنبله نوويه
حتى
الى
الاحتمال او الخيار العسكري في نهايه
الامل
جزء هذا البرنامج انا اعتقد
واضح في نفس الوقت انه هذا الالتجاء
الاخير كما انا ما قلت
والاداره الامريكيه تفضل
الاساليب الاقتصاديه
ودبلوماسيه
السلميه
من مكاسبات هذه القنبله النوويه لكن لو
فاشلت بشكل مطلق او بشكل نهائي كل هذه
المحاولات السلميه هناك احتمال جيد
واا ضربه امريكيه عسكريه ضد
البرنامج العسكري النووي الايراني
والحقيقه انه نحن نار
الاستعداد ما وراء الستار عن همم في
البنتاجون وعند همم الجيش الامريكي
لهذه
السيناريوهات لو كانت ضروريه
لا تسافر مستقبل القريب لكن ربما في المضى
المتوسط هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه
بالنسبه للموقف الامريكي تجاه الاحتجاجات
داخل ايران صحيح
انه همم
الموقف الامريكي مخلوط غير واضح نحن نقول
اننا نساعد وناعم ونشجع
المحتاجين داخل ايران ولكن للاسف في نفس
الوقت ليس هناك مساعده امريكيه
لهؤلاء
شجاعه داخل ايران وانا اعتقد انه
التفسير همم الاساسي هو هكذا
هناك الشكوك في امريكا وفي اماكن اخرى في
العالم حتى في اسرائيل وفي الدول العربيه
هل لهذه الاحتجاجات احتمال جيد للنجاح في
اسقاط هذا النظام الدولي في طيران امل
هو
الاحتمال الارجح فاشل هذه الاحتجاجات
الحقيقه انه للاسف ربما الافضل هو عدم
مساعدات المحتاجين لانهم سوف يكون ضحايا
النظام
ولذلك انا
عاطف انا افهم الموقف الامريكي على الرخم
واضح طيب الى تل ابيب مره اخرى دكتور
اليوم حتى في هذه المقابله واا عن تحالف
الامريكيه يبدو ان نتنياهو لا يقراه كما
تقرا بانه هذه التوام بين الولايات
المتحده وهمم واسرائيل بل انه ربما تعاقب
الادارات يختلف في التعامل همم بحيال هذا
التحالف ما بين امريكا واسرائيل وحتى
الدول الاخرى هو يقول بان ينبغي ان تكون
ان لا تكون هناك تقلبات همم حاده بهذه
العلاقه ما الذي يقصده هنا الى اي مدى هذه
التقلبات موجوده
اذا تمت هناك تقلبات وهي سوف تكون من
الوضع
الراهن الى الاحسن مش للوراء لانه اليوم
معروف بواقفه وهو مش رجل
اتجاه السفينه وهو مصممه الاستمرار
الاتجاه الاستراتيجي الذي قام به في
السنين الطويله الماضيه ولذلك اذا
ممكن ان نتوقع تقلبات هي ازدياد
الدوافع الامريكيه والعربيه تيشرت تهديد
المكمل في تعاظم النووي الايراني واذا
سمحت له ان اقول كلمه بخصوص الاحتجاجات في
ايران
حياك الله
في ايران تمت عبر التاريخ من قبل الشعب
وهكذا سوف يتم ازاله هؤلاء
النظام الايراني
يعني طيب ليس لنا اي شيء تعب الايراني
الباحث السياسي من تل ابيب وكذلك همم من
واشنطن الدكتور بولوكا المستشفى ديفيد
بولوك المستشار السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
ال امريكا وكبير الباحثين في معهد واشنطن
للسياسات الشرق الادنى شكرا جزيلا لك
فيها بعد الفاصل
في استفسار من صناعه ايلون ماسك مستخدموا
تويتر يرفضون استمراره رئيسا للمنصه
العملاق فهل سيصدق ويتنحى ام انها واحده
من فوازير ومناورات الى مصر